the police arrest five Mouse aged
between 17 and 28 years old they were
arrested for an office emblem two of the
mouse were also arrested for assaulting
a police officer and possession of
offensive weapon
all these offenses were committed in the
terminal one of the airports about the
law according to chapter 4 now for
aviation security audience of the Hong
Kong laws section 15 states that if any
person commits whether by means of any
device willfully in an aerodrome serving
International Civil Aviation an act of
violence which courses or is likely to
cause death or serious personal injury
and and dangerous or is likely to enter
the safe operation of the aerodrome or
the safety of persons in the aerodrome
is liable on conviction an indictment to
life imprisonment they one of them is a
reporter from England as I mentioned in
my opening remark for the second one at
a moment we do not have information in
hand however I would like to how they
take the opportunity to state for
travellers or visitors coming to Hong
Kong I believe then they should not be
how they
attacked simply because of the suspicion
of their original professions or origins
of place Hong Kong welcome tourists and
visitors from all the world and we
should disregard of the background of
the visitors we focus on the balance for
the police and you can see the
investigates can bring to bring these
balance protestors in the justice